[Laughter]
here's the thing about partnership right
because we think boyfriend girlfriend
blah blah blah all of that with time
partnership lasts yeah
your boyfriend you're attracted to them
today tomorrow is changing your body is
changing his body is changing
partnership and partnership but that but
that seems like it's 50 50. and to me I
don't I don't wanna okay if you like 50
50 relationships I I prefer
relationships that are a little bit in
more traditional roles where I can like
test my husband's decisions
imagine you have a Business Partnership
and his his interest in your business
was 20 still technically a partner I
think for me partnership just means
someone willing to work with you through
the ups and the Downs through the good
and the bad that's partnership see but
partnership like that it sounds like you
have the same roles and the same input
making where when it's a husband and a
wife that's very clear it's like
different roles yeah like the man's at
the head yeah no yeah but here's the
thing right and I've seen it happening
to my mom what if your your husband is
making the rules today but he can't make
them tomorrow because he's sick he got a
stroke so you have to step up in his
shoes and continue the journey yeah I
mean with the honor of him that's
partnership I mean we could talk about
exceptions but I'm talking about the
rule which is like most people are I
didn't this is good yeah it's for better
War sickness and health yeah yeah
um to me it's just when you when I hear
partnership it just sounds like 50 50. I
just don't like the word so I just
wonder why it's so common here like I
don't want a husband I don't want a
partner I think it's just more figure of
speeches
[Music]
um okay can I ask about the one-sided
yeah yeah okay yeah sure okay so you you
guys do a little bit unconventional of a
relationship right yeah can you tell me
about it so yeah so in the beginning you
know I'll admit it gonna make me sound
like a but in the beginning like I was
like seeing girls behind your back and
then eventually we came to terms with
the fact that you know we're just like
what made it work the best was that I'm
just fully upfront and honest about all
of it and then we have like certain
rules so like I don't have girls sleep
over I don't go on dates with girls
um I shower if I see a girl you know I
shower afterwards and stuff like that
um but I'll let you speak to it because
it was like a big process in the
beginning I mean it's definitely not
normal no it was like step by step you
know like
um like I used to like before I I've
always liked the girl so it wasn't like
a big deal for me like be actually
attracted for girls so and I don't think
it was like a trend like for me at the
time because like I would look different
so uh two girls that's enemy and was
like step by step so first thing like uh
actually we started our relationship
really fast was like we started like
dating for real like in two three weeks
it was like super super fast
and was like one thing at the time one
day at a time I wasn't like okay with a
everything but like I think the way that
we built this thing this like
relationship with a lot of like
um
um like rules like try and air was like
I decided to stay through all of that
and we were really happy now but it's
like of course it's not like I should
never had a threesome she's like prior
to prior to dating me she never had a
threesome and now she's had like over 75
right so like like even last night right
we go to the Ministry of Sound we see a
girl we like and then she approaches the
girl likes us she comes back with us and
it's cool but like it's more just like a
fun thing for us but I also see girls
Inside by myself right but all the like
love and affection and companionship is
with her and other girls are more just
for fun didn't you guys do like you had
multiple girls living in the house yeah
yeah in 2021
um we moved two girls in and then we
moved to third girl and we had there was
like some rotating girls in living for
periods of time but at the height of it
there was like three girls besides her
it got to be too much for her and she
left and like I lasted like another week
after that and I just kicked the other
girls out and moved her back in and said
like let's not live with girls anymore I
was gonna ask if how do you not get
jealous because I'm like I would be so
jealous yeah because two of the girls
fell in love with me and it was like a
big it was like it was like non-stop
drama I was trying to basically try what
Hugh Hefner was doing where he was
living with like again the girls next
door and it sounded good Theory but in
practice you know people there's like so
much drama every day about every little
thing so it's like lots of stress lots
of BS like I think the jealous part is
like about like I was okay like living
with the girls but like the part is when
you put a bunch of people together to
live together like the real world kind
of thing it's like it's like those TV
shows like those
um shows you know that people started
like arguing for nothing it's like so
much drama all the time and what would
like make me like really bad is like it
was like for nothing like for example
juice and someone said oh but you should
take orange juice and then no no I'm
gonna take off oh my god did you see
that still there oh my God oh my
gosh it's like everything every little
thing is like you know but the part
about me not getting jealous is because
I don't know I just don't like uh like
my first relationship like I started
like my relationship with when I was 18
it lasts almost three years right and in
the end of like my relationship like I
was with such a nice guy but it was like
truly truly nice you know and I was it
was really really cool and like in the
end of our my relationship with him like
I tried to help him like to be with
other girl you know that was like a
friend of him that he had a crush it
before and she was like really cool she
was like so sweet and I was like no you
guys should be together now you know
and like that thing about jealousy is
something that doesn't bother me so it
was like this because I think it's
natural for the men to have other women
so you you were more annoyed with the
girls in the house you weren't even
jealous no whether it was gel not
jealous but like Superman is like the
amount of that happens every
day for nothing yeah because like are
you like I used to work I was like doing
my like engineer job I'm like civil
engineer I used to work and I would come
back home and they would treat me like
the boss for example all the girls would
come with me with problems and like
scenes like John works a lot I always
took like the part of the houses my
responsibility so I hate for example
imagine like a lamp uh it's not working
right it's like I don't I won't even go
to him like to say oh that's not working
let's no I'll go there try to fix when
he has to come to me to say oh that
wasn't working I feel like I failed on
that because like I that part for me you
know so it was like I would come to the
house and one of the girls oh did you
see that the maid didn't do that oh but
she was supposed to do that and so it
was like dude you could have solved that
while you're making this a thing you
know go there talk to the person talk to
the mail like like you don't need me to
like to come to see what's going on and
then I would take one part one side like
oh I think it's better but then the
other part would be like is the is the
would you say the culture in Brazil is a
bit different is that much more open
yeah like most girls are bisexual like
most girls are kind of like sexually
liberated
um like we would go out to the clubs
together we'd end up bring home like you
know two other groups of girls a lot of
nights so we had like a stripper pull in
the house so there'd be a lot of nights
we get back to the house there's like 10
Brazilian girls like running around
naked in the house I'm like the only guy
yeah I think we have more open yeah how
does it work that way around so if she
brings back a dude well that's not loud
I've got a question about this as well
so this is I've never come across anyone
that has this setup
do you think that you're okay with how
you're living because he meets your
other needs like does he meet your needs
emotionally so is that does that make it
okay okay because like when like what I
like when he goes out like to the other
place to bring is like he comes back
happy if he's happy my life like becomes
like
so much easier you know like if it comes
like if it comes back of a smile oh it's
okay I always ask how is your banking oh
it's okay cool nice but like what she
always says have a nice banging before I
go because I have a second place now
like we're doing it like in the same
house and I gotta be too much like there
was literally there's like quality
problems there's like periods of time
when those three girls live in the house
where I was still having other girls
over all the time and the three girls
would like be in their room while I'd
have other girls I had like two stars
two floors place so it was like easier
because the uh the up floor was like a a
setup like with food nice stuff the the
bar you know so it would like use the
other but it's like was too much of that
time so then why why do you think that
you need more women is it because you
can't live without sex which is what we
know I just like like I devoted my whole
life towards like you know the dating
game and and I just enjoy like going
through the whole process and stuff like
that and if you look like you know back
in history like monogamy isn't natural
anyway it was mostly imposed by by the
church in the state to have familiar
units and stuff like that it's not
natural at all if you look at the animal
kingdom and stuff like that right
there's like a tribal leader like in
monkeys for instance and that sleeps
with all the different females and the
females are all attracted to that tribal
leader but they'll go to other tribes
and try to sleep with the alpha leader
of that tribe right and then there'll be
like fights and stuff then you think
that's like
a self-esteem thing though because I'm
trying to look at the I'm trying to get
D also you're not monkey because yeah
because I'm thinking because I'm from a
Caribbean culture
and African culture I've got both sides
and I'm telling you right now
I
I'm too
no it just could not happen like it
could not happen and I think also in the
UK like what she's saying have you ever
read it have you ever been in a
situationship
yeah so you're sharing a guy anyway
without knowing yeah I've been in a
relationship and the man's been for the
streets but yeah no I hear that I hear
that but actually like
like yeah
would you rather they lie to you and you
just don't know could you be okay with
it if you didn't know
wait no I wouldn't be that with the
person but you wouldn't know yeah yeah
most it's like the truth you know yeah
it's like the thing is about to like he
can be like sure like he that he sits my
base my by my side yeah and he opens his
mouth like to tell me anything he can be
sure like the truth because there's no
lines yeah because men are gonna do what
they want anyway and that's that's why
it's better for communication which I
understand it's so authentic I'll tell
you something though and I all due
respect to you right but men will find
it at least a man that I'm surrounded by
and I'm 32 and I I I'm surrounded by
loads of men especially high quality men
coaches blah blah blah but anyway
men will find it very difficult to get
married to a prostitute just because of
her work period
and other way around I think woman is
the same right some man will marry a
prostitute but on the promise of like
okay she will change her job blah blah
blah but you will find a very difficult
for a man to settle down with a
prostitute I've dated a lot of strippers
for instance like that they were like
but did you get married to them no but
like I had a lot of stripper girlfriends
in different places yeah girlfriends is
different I wasn't married and having
children
to a stripper or a prostitute now listen
there's there's a lot of prostitutes
that are amazing girls then they're out
there doing that job to support their
families and their circumstances it's
just different better than me 100 now
but they do get pushed down or like not
looked at because they're prostitutes or
strippers it's the same for men the
quality of men and he can make a lot of
money whatever it is wait you think it's
the same for a man when they've slept
around when they slept around and they
were openly sharing about it and it's
just everyone knows about it the quality
yeah
are women skeptical
and reluctant to sleep with Drake
now here is the thing right this is the
thing now
um definitely I will just answer your
question it's a No-No right and they're
not yes what about I'm gonna ask you
another what about rappers look at Nick
Cannon and he's got all the babies
who are they going for yeah if they're
going for a certain type of girls that's
like unknown they earn less than them
um they kind of like structure yeah they
will not hesitate in two seconds as many
of you know I was just banned on Tick
Tock and we are demonetized on a daily
basis on this platform if you want to
help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible